this is a simple example where we want
to just apply the formula for
conditional probabilities and see what
we get
the example involves a four-sided die if
you can imagine such an object which we
roll twice and we record the first roll
and the second roll so there are 16
possible outcomes we assume to keep
things simple that each one of those 16
possible outcomes each one of them has
the same probability so each outcome has
probability 1 over 16 let us consider
now a particular event B on which we're
going to condition this is the event
under which the smaller of the two die
rolls is equal to 2 which means that one
of the dice must have resulted in 2 and
the other die has resulted in something
which is 2 or larger so this can happen
in multiple ways and here are the
different ways that it can happen so a 2
2 or 2 3 a 2 4 then a 3 2 and the 4 2
all these are outcomes in which one of
the dice has a value equal to 2 and the
other die is at least as large so we
condition on this event these results in
a conditional model where each one of
those five outcomes are equally likely
Cindy since they used to be equally
likely in the original model now let us
look at this quantity the maximum of the
two die rolls that is the largest of the
results and let us try to calculate the
following quantity the conditional
probability that the maximum is equal to
1 given that the minimum is equal to 2
so this is the conditional probability
of this particular outcome well this
particular outcome cannot happen if I
tell you that the smaller number is 2
then the larger number cannot be equal
to 1 so this outcome is impossible and
therefore this conditional probability
is equal to
zero let's do something a little more
interesting let us now look at the
conditional probability that the maximum
is equal to three given the information
that event B has occurred it's best to
draw a picture and see what that event
corresponds to M is equal to three the
maximum is equal to three if one of the
dies resulted in a three and the other
died resulting in something that's three
or less so this event here corresponds
to the blue region in this diagram now
let us try to calculate the conditional
probability by just following the
definition the conditional probability
of one event given another is the
probability that both of them both of
the two events occur divided by the
probability of the conditioning event
that is out of the probable total
probability in the conditioning event we
ask what fraction of that probability is
assigned to outcomes in which the event
of interest is also happening so what is
this event the maximum is equal to 3
which is the blue event and
simultaneously the red event is
happening these two events intersect
only in two places this is the
intersection of the two events and the
probability of that intersection is two
out of 16 since there's 16 outcomes and
that event happens only with two
particular outcomes so this gives us 2
over 16 in the numerator how about the
denominator event B consists of a total
of 5 possible outcomes each one has
probability 1/16 so this is 5 over 16 so
the final answer is 2 over 5 we could
have gotten that same answer in a simple
and more perhaps more intuitive way in
the original model all outcomes were
equally likely therefore in the
conditional model the five outcomes that
belong to B should also be equally
likely
out of those five there's two of them
that make the event of interest to occur
so given that we live in B there's two
ways out of five that the event of
interest will materialize so the event
of interest has conditional probability
equals to 2/5